the prevention of covidre vaccine and
then i love it
when we've got the whole idea here with
pinar
is that she represents this supply chain
and therefore
the vaccine distribution so together
from the
understanding of the pandemic and
through public health and i loved how dr
fauci said those two primary areas we're
not only
building up our public health
institution and systems
but also the science and the research
that will get us to the better
understanding to have the facts to be
able to prevent
and or understand how to be prepared for
whatever comes
next so we're going to ask them a couple
of questions
i've told them all they're enthusiastic
quick
and punchy because they have the real
essence
of the hope for who we are as a
community and especially today with
social courage
these three have evidence that evidenced
it as well
so first to you carlos from your
perspective
your vantage point tell me what you
think is going to happen relative to
being prepared
for the next whatever the next is
well you know i think the first thing is
we have to acknowledge that we fail in
this in the response to this pandemic
and yet we thought we were prepared we
had pandemic plans we had all sorts of
of things that you know in a global
security index the us was ranked as
number one as being the country most
prepared
and yeah we have had the the country
with the biggest failure right we
represent
for less than five percent of the world
population we're about 23 24
of cases of deaths so obviously we have
to recognize that we fail and then we
need to see well
why did we fail what parts we were not
able to prepare for
and the number one failure we had as a
country was a failure of leadership
and because leadership is critical at a
time of crisis
and and everybody in the business
community knows that and when you don't
have the right leader at a time crisis
then you're going to fail
and unfortunately you can't prepare for
leadership leadership just happens when
the pandemic occurs so you're not
you can't say well let's plan my
pandemic so it happens exactly when i
have the
leadership that i need so then you say
well what could we've done well the
second thing
is is we weakened
those institutions that were there to
respond
when you know when when a pandemic
happens and that includes the cdc that
includes the fda
and sidelining the cdc in my mind was
particularly
a gracious mistake because it was first
of all
it's personal uh it's it's here in
atlanta
it's part of our community it's our
friends our neighbors but our people
that we know
and we know the expertise and we know
the the the value that's
that that cdc has as a global health
agency
and to see cdc essentially be moved out
of the of the
of the response from very early on in my
mind
was was clearly one of the greatest
mistakes we made
and the you know the third one is that
we
we did not let science uh
uh guide the response we let politics
write that response and
and as as as dr jim curran says you know
public health has always been political
politics is part of what we do
but it has never been partisan and in my
wildest dreams i would have never grant
that a face mask will become a political
symbol
that a vaccine today people are talking
about whether there's
more you know hesitancy in republicans
or here
that i mean this is this doesn't make
any sense so making public health
partisan i think we may keep things that
are technical
political and by doing that i think we
we weaken our response and then the last
thing that i think
we failed and something we really need
to think about as a country
is that our our nation our health system
our public health
is typically run at the state level you
cannot run
a pandemic response at a state level
this is a little bit like trying to run
a war
you will not go to war and tell every
state well you recruit your own soldiers
to get your own things
and then we'll meet you up in whatever
europe or where we're gonna fight
because you know we'll get there and see
what we can do we would have never won
the second world war have we done that
you know here's the
georgia army here's the massachusetts
army and that's not how a country
responds
and having had 50 different response
plans
throughout this pandemic i think was a
major problem so the question really the
difficult question is at what point in
time
do you have a national strategy
supersede and then and right we're
living right now
i mean pandemic the response is
vaccination it's a mess and it's a mess
because
every state has different requirements
every states have different responses
there's not a national plan so i think
at some point in time we're going to
have to look at those issues
because if not we will fail again in the
next pandemic i love it it's that whole
leadership thread
with the expertise the science and the
execution
so i love it so thank you very much
because that leads us to joshua
as we talk about testing and so
beautifully looking at community
implementation
what do you see we learned a lot from
this pandemic and some of what we
learned is that we had to build things
on the fly
and so in thinking about where we are
now and it's important to keep in mind
we're not done
and i think that's going to be a theme
we heard partly today
yes we are moving towards hopefully an
end game but we can't give up those
things that have eventually been shown
to work like
masking and distancing and testing is
part of an integrative approach to keep
cases down even as we get immunity the
right way the safe way through vaccines
so we look forward i think that
investment of the things that have
worked have got to be in place
earlier and if we're going to reason
given uncertainty
because what happens often early is we
have to make decisions using
limited data but then the data is key
and if i go back in time about a year
prior to now
some of the earliest understanding of
person-to-person transmission
was because of genomic surveillance data
that allowed us to see clusters that
were not coming
let's say from uh an environmental
source but had the same
signatures of individuals who had no
connection to that source indicating
we have a human-to-human issue at hand
without that surveillance we would have
even been farther behind
so once we get those for surveillance
systems in place
then we can start to see the value of
more information
testing people is not something that is
a passive activity
what we've shown and many other
institutions have shown is that testing
can be a form of
active mitigation that not only are we
getting data that it's becoming part of
decision support systems
and so i guess the last thought i would
have with respect to the next which is
still
now plus the next which is to really
think about
infrastructure development both because
we need to support basic science and
principal development
but also because we need to reinvest in
things like a national forecasting
center
and not because we want that forecasting
center to tell us the bad news
and then the bad news comes and hits us
but because that supports new actions
that we could be taking
and eventually that's going to have to
connect to community skills
because the community partners are going
to be essential if we're going to take
those principles turn them into tools
and then eventually turn them into
action but i'd love to hear again the
thread between carlos and you
is that you still have to what we know
is what we know today
and building on that in terms of the
long-term leadership and it's also
between the two of you it's the sort of
the think the think global but it still
has to act
locally in terms of the communities in
which those partnerships exist
and yet we need a national plan
directive perfect because
right bernard once we have a plan we
have to have it
distributed so let's hear a little bit
about from your perspective
on that whole supply chain and vaccine
distribution
when we have a plan right
so the first thing i would like to
mention is that we really need to
rethink
the design of our health care systems
the pandemic highlighted the
vulnerabilities the gaps
in those systems they've been operating
at fairly high capacity even before the
pandemic because that's how they were
designed
high utilization minimized cost
and they were designed for the most part
for sick care
not for health care in part because of
the financial incentives in place
so as we rethink it's really important
for us to redesign reading our
healthcare systems
to focus on promoting health supporting
healthy behaviors
putting incentives in place for healthy
behaviors so really shifting the focus
from this care to healthcare
um the second thing i think the the
pandemic highlighted this was mentioned
uh by my co-panelists as well as about
by dr farci and wallensky
is the disparities we have seen
disparities
you know very very glaringly in health
outcomes
hospitalizations deaths as well as
infections
in people of color are much higher than
than other communities so as we rethink
the design of our healthcare systems
it's very important for us to also make
sure that we have
access and equity to everyone regardless
of their background color where they
live
where they live so that we can have a
more equitable
access to these services and healthier
communities
so supply chains again the
vulnerabilities in health supply chains
medical supply
chains pharmaceutical supply chains
we've seen
lots of issues during the pandemic so
it's very important for us to first and
foremost have the information the vital
information that we need so we
understand
what do we have where what do we need
so that we can actually bring the demand
and supply together
especially during a crisis this is very
difficult to do this
on the fly so you really need to have
many of these in place
ahead of time so that you are ready uh
when the crisis hits and the final thing
that i would like to mention
is the importance of collaboration and
coordination
between different organizations whether
it's government
private sector ngos academia
and it's important to establish these
collaborations different roles
uh connections ahead of time because
again this is very
difficult established during a crisis
situation
so our nation is is has been the leader
in science technology but we failed
in coming together bringing things
together
and mobilizing our resources uh
for effective quoted 19 response so for
future
i think this is another very important
aspect for us to have
these connections and different pieces
together so
when the crisis comes uh people know
what they need to do where when so that
we can respond in an efficient and
effective fashion
what a difference a year makes from the
point of
all the unknowns and y'all y'all putting
it up together and for those of us who
were sitting in our homes on march 13th
oh this will be done in two weeks we'll
be ready and what we've seen over time
and we talk about literally what a
difference a year makes and of course dr
falchi mentioned that
is that today there's much more
intention there's focus
crossing the silos collaboratives
between the public and the
not-for-profit the ngos as well as
the organizations like cdc and the
carter center
is to bringing them together to focus on
how we move forward instead of
all scrambling so i love that thank you
and i think that's where so much of the
the difference in the year back to
leadership
focus intention resource allocation
and new ways of communicating that will
be critical
because what i think is if we look at
the not only how you prepare
for the future it's where do we see
bright spots
whether it's domestically or globally
that can make us
think oh there is hope there's some
optimism out there
other than the difference in a year and
pannar i'm going to start with you this
time
where do you see hope um
some organizations have done a good job
in making sure that
they operate safely bring back their
communities safely i think georgia tech
has been one of those bright spots um
like dr cabrera president cabrera
mentioned earlier we don't have a public
health school we don't have a medical
school
but we were able to implement
testing tracing isolation
and now vaccination all of this is
happening on campus
and i think the leadership
on campus has been key in making this
happen
as well as the participation from
everyone on campus commitment from
everyone
on campus students faculty staff
leadership
um and the the i think
the the way the leadership communicated
openly
to the community broader community as
well as received
input from various constitute
constituents within our community
i think that has been key one of the
reasons i love being a georgia tech
and why i came to georgia tech is
because of the collaborative spirit here
and i think this collaborative spirit
shined probably like never before
with so many of us coming together
during this time of crisis
um and i hope this uh gives hope and
um sets a nice example for others as
well
that is so cool i love that story and
president cabrera you mentioned it where
you said well we've never done it but
we'll do it we'll do it
let's do it we'll just get it done bring
everybody to the table and get it done
so i think that spirit
the georgia tech way needs to be
expanded across
many campuses as well as across the
country
the collaborative yes out of our comfort
zone like dr
lucy said out of our comfort zone we'll
manage
move on so tell us when you were talking
about joshua your part
i mean yeah your partner in crime here
how where do you see hope i don't want
to steal
carlos's thunder by saying vaccines can
i say vaccines
is he hope right here hope is sitting
right next door
honestly i am deeply optimistic
about the change of direction here
because of the
widespread availability of highly
effective vaccines i think that should
bring
all of us enormous hope and optimism
now with respect to lessons learned now
the
negative there would be we give up on
the other items as those become
available
so what has been a bright spot to me in
this past six to nine months
is precisely the way in which community
members have come together often with
very disparate expertise
so i want to be clear i'm sitting up
here with colleagues today
there is a very large team my colleague
gibson in particular
on the laboratory side logistics
folks who have figured out much more
effectively than having me as your
technician trying to figure out a way to
make
a saliva-based sampling testing system
fast and efficient and easy
a whole team of folks from
communications to logistics to
scientists
who've come together in common purpose
in a sense of service of trying to serve
the
community inform the community sometimes
tell them when things are not
going so well that we have to even when
things are going well we have to be
aware that that
may not be the case a few weeks from now
that we have to remain vigilant
i think those kind of interactions and
collaborations
can be the basis for improvements in the
future whether it's because we're going
to be better prepared or even take that
same collaborative spirit
and develop a new technology in advance
or system in advance or
even be more ready to communicate at
scale like this question of
communicating risks in a different way
so that people can take their own health
into their own hands and try to make
more informed choices but going back to
my first point all of this now
with respect to getting us through this
non-pharmaceutical route
obviously all the investment that was
done very early
whether it's moderna or pfizer j j are
putting us in a much better place
right now than we were even just a few
months ago
this is both inspiring and informing and
informative thank you joshua so much i
i'm thinking about um the story dr
falchi said about every single person in
the scientific community has a part to
play
they may think their part is very small
but in the big scheme if
we didn't have it we wouldn't get where
we are so i love how you're talking
about the team approach
the trusted approach and how you
communicate it okay
dr del rio now he's dr del rio so so
what
what what is the i mean one of the right
spots i mean
to me the the one bright spot and one we
need to emphasize
is is the value and the triumph
of science and of research uh it is the
investment in research that has gotten
us vaccines and has gotten us to where
we are
and i think we you know the u.s spends a
fair amount of
percentage of gdp and research to the
nih and the national science foundation
etc
and frequently here politicians say well
why what do we get out of this well
we get the kind of things like the
vaccine we have right now and i think
telling the story about how supporting
basic research
actually has tremendous implications to
where we are so i think that
a bright spot has been that the the
investment of years in research has paid
off
and i think has gotten us to a much
better place the
the second thing is i think that a
bright spot has been
the the response of of
thousands of humans around the world and
i you know i talked about many people
but i want to refer right now to health
care workers
uh you know who have have been there
in in a very difficult circumstance and
now for a year taking care of sick
people and frankly being you know tired
and exhausted and it's been really
really hard when you have you know
people coming in that
that you have not much you can do once
they get really sick and
you know five six seven percent of them
are still dying in the hospital
and it makes me think about
the uh you know uh dr
uh uh jonathan who was the director of
the national
uh of the of the global program on aids
many years ago
and an internationally safe aids
conference he said back in 1998 he said
you know when the history of aids is
written our biggest contribution may be
that at the time of plague
within that fleet we did not hide we did
not separate
and i think the fact that people could
have walked away and say look i don't
need this job i don't need to put myself
at risk i go somewhere else
because there were you know there have
been thousands of healthcare workers
around the world that have gotten
infected
and people are still taking care of
individuals and i think you know
the human condition compassion caring
has really been prominent throughout
this pandemic and i think again we need
to think about
how do we capitalize on that how do we
get away from
our individualistic cells and really
move into a more
you know sort of community approach to
because what pinar was saying about
health disparities you know health
disparities are
are in great part as doctor factory said
the result of
social inequalities and and and and
things are happening in our society that
we need to start caring about
housing education food access many
things that have nothing to do with
with health care but have everything to
do with health
so thinking about how do we address some
of those things i think could
potentially be some of the
positive bright sides of this pandemic
is that we may eventually
i think come out of this really taking
equity
and and justice as a much more serious
thing that we've done up to now
and aim into that as dr felty was even
talking about the bright light
the shining the light on the entire
community which is a part of a health
story
whether you have the house in which to
safely live the food to remain in your
health
to be able to say um i began to get
educated so your
the whole community is so much a part of
positive health as well as access
to good health care and i love how you
said obviously as you heard from
president cabrera i came from ibm
and we were one of the largest research
investors in the world
and to be able to know that that kind of
research
and patents and creative and innovative
brains were working because
that's what i loved about the work that
was happening
in the research arena where kizzy
corbett was right there having worked on
this with many of you
over decades well not she's young but i
mean the work that been going on for
decades and it comes to fruition in
times of need
so that's a part of that bright spot but
carlos you just mentioned a lot about
why we're here
social courage and for many of us we've
seen that in the face of the health
workers
the health the people who are taking
care of the children of the health
workers
the parents who've been at home during
this time doing
home schooling which is not an easy job
i'd love
for you all to think about that and
where have you seen
social courage within either yourself or
others and how did it impacted you
especially in light of the celebration
today
as i love dr falchi not just him but all
those that have been a part of this
journey for the last year and actually
as we've heard for decades
carlos would you like to answer that or
respond to that
i mean i think you think about you know
there's been many
people that have talked about courage
and the importance of courage but i
think about you know winston churchill
and others you know
courage is not the absence of fear
courage is really the ability
to do the right thing in in on on
difficult circumstances right and i
think throughout this
this pandemic you can put you know
countless examples of people who have
done exactly that
who have not remained quiet who have
worked very hard who have stepped out of
the
of the comfort zone in order to do the
right thing
and work together across uh institutions
across nations across
communities doing you know doing what
needs to be done
to address the pandemic and and that i
think to me
is is is what the courage that we need
and we need
more of that in our society because i
worry that
that again people are beginning to say
well you know
this is over when are we going to get
back to
to the way things were we're not going
to get back to normal and
i tell people we don't want to go back
to the normal
that we lived at we want to go forward
in a much
better normal and that's going to take
courage to do that it's going to be
take courage to be disruptive and to be
different and i think we
you know we're going to have to disrupt
higher education we're here in this
you know in this campus of georgia tech
i mean how are we going to change our
education going forward what have we
learned out of this pandemic
what can we do to make access to
education more affordable and better to
everybody
as opposed to a few individuals so i
think using the pandemic as a way to
to really leap forward and get us to a
better place it's going to take
enormous courage and i think that all of
us need to think about
how do we do that the whole new word is
reimagining and i go forward strategy
we don't have to just go back it's to go
forward
thank you thank you thank you joshua
what have you been thinking about
courage social courage i think dr
fauci expressed it succinctly which is
that sometimes courage can mean
telling the truth speaking the science
telling the facts however inconvenient
and about a year ago a little bit more
than a year ago
today we hosted a rapid response form at
georgia tech in early february
and one of the speakers was trevor
bedford some of you may know him he's a
genomic epidemiologist in some sense
someone who does detective work by
looking
at sequences of viruses and trying to
understand origins
and he describes seeing this pattern
that seemed to indicate
human to human transmission and then
spending all the time he could telling
as many as people
as possible and then making a strategic
decision
to go spend much more of his time he's a
basic scientist
using a platform that really he had
developed and was ready for this moment
called neck string
to spend the time communicating and
sharing exactly how severe this could be
and how much action was needed and so i
think that's an example
it's a different kind of brain you might
say but in the in the realm of science
this actually was that kind of
decision strategic decision to pursue
evidence and truth and share it
even if it's inconvenient and i think
that kind of courage is infectious let
me say in a positive sense
meaning when i saw that i had seen his
work on next straight and i thought
a few years ago why is he making
websites and then when i saw it a year
ago i said i know why he's made why
aren't
i doing more of that why aren't others
doing more things like that of
translating and we've made strategic
decisions
here with a colleague cleo andrus and
design and computing
to try to take elements of risk that we
felt
were understandable but then turn it
into a tool that others could access
democratizing access to information in a
way that people could make a decision
is it actually risky to go in that crowd
of 20 or 50 it was hard to make those
sort of tangible decisions
so i think in that sense that began to
spread not just to me and my team
but to others in the team and you can
start to realize that that opportunity
is challenging
but how do we go outside our academic
circles and really bring that out to the
community and that
comes with risk but it comes with real
opportunities to make a bigger
difference
brilliant because i think that's what so
often people are hesitant to get out of
their comfort zone take the risk ask the
question
develop the idea with the intent
or the fear fear often reigns in terms
of
giving us not as much confidence
to take the risk so i love hearing that
is it taking the risk and then having
the application
a ripple effect brilliant thanks joshua
pannar what are you thinking about
social courage and what effect it has on
you
i mean just just to add um a different
perspective to
uh to my colleagues um i i think about
every single person
in this country in the world um
during the pandemic all the difficulties
they are going through it takes courage
to wake up every day to put one foot in
front of the other and to keep going
um in the u.s we lost about half a
million people to covet
that's a huge number that's about the
population of the city of atlanta
imagine an
entire city wiped out um
probably each and every one of us lost a
friend
a loved one a family member or know
someone who did
so it's really it's been really
difficult for i think every single
person
um and um i you know on the personal
side i
would like to acknowledge my students my
graduate students in particular
the courage it took to them to stop what
else they were doing
and work day and night especially during
the
early months uh non-stop on covet
related research
um because they cared and they wanted to
make an impact
and uh you know from our georgia tech
community again earlier in the pandemic
there was a time when we thought that
some of the guidance that you were
receiving from higher level
organizations
was not exactly sufficient for us to
maintain
safety on campus and to bring people
back to campus
and a group of faculty members got
together
following signs a lot of deliberation
wrote a statement basically saying
um we need to do things a little bit
differently than you know what we are
hearing
um to establish and ensure physical
distancing for example so we need more
flexibility in our modes of teaching
and we need masks on campus this was at
a time when
masks were not required or mandated but
we thought we really needed masks
to make this a safe place so it took
courage for
that group to come together to speak up
uh and
uh to be proactive rather than reactive
uh to ensure
safety and health health and well-being
of the of the population
i think unfortunately our time is up but
you have heard three voices of courage
you'll understand what it means from a
global perspective of the folks affected
and impacted by
this covet but also the work that each
of them have done
over time and to you we're so grateful
because it does
exhibit the at-home real people that do
courageous things every day and to you
carlos and joshua and panara i am so
grateful and humbled to be on the stage
with you and president cabral
for letting us be on this stage to
celebrate
not just dr falchi but the brave souls
who are working every day
in community to be prepared for that
next pandemic
thank you thank you thank you you all
are my hero she rose thank you so much
[Applause]
well let me add my appreciation to you
and for the for moderating the panel for
the
to the three of you um
not not just for obviously for for this
incredibly interesting and insightful
conversation but most importantly for
what you have been doing this year
and i think all of you mentioned it and
and i do recognize that there's a lot of
people
behind you and in other groups and
throughout georgia tech and through our
universities around
the the country but um i am grateful to
everyone each one of you and let this
moment be a reminder to all of us of
uh what an incredibly important
function we have as as universities
dedicated to research to educating new
generations
think about it there's no other
institution in our society
that can't do the kinds of things that
we are called
to do let this be a reminder
that it's not always easy it's not
always pleasant
but it's absolutely essential that we
deliver on our mission
thank you all very much for being with
us today much appreciated
[Music]
[Music]
is
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
thank you for coming are you based here
in atlanta yeah
what types of things do you typically
cover
[Music]
oh gosh if it has been nice
or is it still is that still on your
radar no i mean once the inauguration
happens
in january
everything is eyes are still on georgia
right now exactly
well we appreciate you coming like
um
two three
you